[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débrief du docte
l'arctique se réchauffe deux fois plus
vite que le reste de la planète
principale conséquence il devient plus
aisé de circuler sur la banquise avec la
fonte des glaces et cette partie du
monde riche en gaz et en or noir attise
les convoitises
en 2014 la russie est devenue le premier
pays à extraire du pétrole arctique mais
exploiter ces richesses reste encore un
immense défi comme nous allons voir dans
ce documentaire a retrouvé sur rt france
arco l'or noir de la banquise et pour
décrypter les enjeux de l'exploitation
pétrolière vos accueillons olivier
appert il est l'ancien pdg d'its fp
énergies nouvelles et il préside
notamment aujourd'hui le conseil
français de l'énergie olivier appert est
également délégué général de l'académie
des technologies chien bonjour olivier
appert merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france bonjour alors
comment vous l'avez trouvé ce
documentaire arrco l'or noir de la
banquise est ce que cette immersion au
coeur de la plateforme russe pris la
zone là la reflète bien la réalité du
terrain
ce reportage est effectivement très
intéressant et ça montre bien les
difficultés d'exploitation pétrolière et
gazière dans des conditions extrêmes
comme le com et contre celles que l'on
rencontre en arctique déjà l'offshore
est quand même compliquée mais
l'offshore en arctique pose quand même
des problèmes tout à fait spécifique
alors on va regarder sans attendre tout
de suite un premier extrait darko l'or
noir de la banquise prirazlomnaïa se
développent et le nombre de puits
augmente
un nouveau forage va paraît
m
dans cette configuration il ne faut pas
se dépêcher le plus important est de
s'assurer de la qualité du travail et de
la sécurité la vitesse de descente est
très limité c'est à dire que cela prend
4 minutes de descendre chaque tuyau à 9
mètres plus bas en profondeur la
descente sera encore plus lente afin de
ne pas endommager le câble
tous les puits de prirazlomnaïa
pénétrons dans la couche pétrolifères
comme les tentacules d'une énorme
pieuvre leur longueur totale sera de 200
kilomètres tout le pétrole extrait
arrive dans des réservoirs spéciaux qui
se trouve à l'intérieur de la plateforme
c'est ce qu'on appelle la méthode du
mythe de stockage le pétrole se trouve
dans les conteneurs de stockage
il en a douze au total il est hébergé
afin d'éviter la formation d'un mélange
air gaz et de minimiser ainsi les
hypothétiques risque d'explosion
prirazlomnaïa repose sur les fonds
marins à 20 mètres de profondeur ces
fondations consiste en un caisson si
solide qu'il peut résister à un séisme
de magnitude 6 olivier appert est ce
qu'il faut considérer cette région
polaire en arctique comme un eldorado en
matière d'exploitation à des ressources
naturelles l'arctique soulève quand même
un intérêt croissant pour le potentiel
en matière de production pétrolière et
gazière l'article
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être de l'ordre
de 4 % des terres émergées les réserves
sont estimées les réserves qui sont
contenues en arctique sont estimées à 5
% des réserves prouvées mondiale et en
ce qui concerne en particulier le gaz le
la zone arctique représente de l'ordre
de 75 de 25 % des réserves prouvées de
gaz naturel ce qui est quand même tout à
fait considérable il ya de nombreux pays
qui convoitent ces richesse
hydrocarbures la russie les états unis
le canada la norvège le danemark
l'islande notamment le temps c'est vrai
de la guerre froide et est révolue mais
dans quelle mesure cette région région
stratégique reste un terrain de bataille
géopolitique à bâle l'accès aux
ressources est effectivement un enjeu
géopolitique important ça fait l'objet
la délimitation ont fait
deux des zones exclusives a fait l'objet
de nombreux débats et de nombreuses
discussions voire même de conflits forte
en ce qui concerne à la fois la pêche
mais aussi en ce qui concerne les
ressources naturelles en particulier les
hydrocarbures
fort heureusement en 2018
un accord a été signé par l'ensemble des
partenaires
les six pays limitrophes auquel on se
sont rajoutés à la fois la finlande et
la suède
les sept accords de 2018 règle les
problèmes en ce qui concerne
l'exploitation dela des ressources de la
pêche le récemment aussi à accord a été
obtenu entre la russie et la norvège sur
la délimitation de la frontière sur la
mer de barents ce qui permet de
développer ces ressources de façon plus
sûre au plan géopolitique il ya une
question aussi qui fait l'objet de
contentieux c'est le statut des détroits
les pays qui se disputent la
souveraineté donc un territoria avec une
approche juridique différente les russes
les canadiens considèrent l'article
comme une mer intérieure alors que les
etats-unis défendent plutôt liberté de
navigation au niveau des détroits sur
cette question là où est-ce qu'on en est
à écouter c on n'est pas encore sorti de
l'auberge
on va le sujet en fait va devenir de
plus en plus important dans la mesure où
suite au réchauffement des zones
arctiques la circulation en dans cette
zone maritime va devenir de plus en plus
va être facilitée va devenir de plus en
plus importante et donc ça rendra le
problème de plus en plus importants et
avec la nécessité d'arriver à un accord
intergouvernemental sur ce sujet
justement tel type d'accord sur l'envoi
c'est pas à moi de me substituer aux
aux responsables politiques par ailleurs
que la france est intéressé par les
sujets l'arctique et l'antarctique mais
on n'est pas directement partie prenante
des négociations
vous citez la france c'est vrai que la
france comme de nombreux pays européens
lorgnent aussi une part du gâteau c'est
le cas aussi de la chine
d'ailleurs ces pays disposent d'un siège
d'observateur au sein d'un forum de
discussion n'a pas vraiment de pouvoir
contraignant il s'agit du conseil de
l'article où en sont leurs ambitions la
chine cherche effectivement investir
dans des ressources pétrolières et
gazières mondiales
pour l'instant les ambitions pas parce
que la chine la croissance économique de
la chine dépend de ses
approvisionnements en pétrole et en gaz
pour l'instant les ambitions ont plutôt
porté sur la sur l'afrique ou sur le
moyen-orient
en ce qui concerne la zone arctique
les enjeux pour la chine sont plus ceux
liés à ceux dont on parlait tout à
l'heure c'est la liberté de circulation
pour faciliter à la fois les
importations en chine et aussi les
exportations de chine
et s'agissant des pays européens de la
france notamment la france n'est n'a pas
un poids quand même très important la
matière on est préoccupés en fait par
l'impact du show du réchauffement
climatique et les bénéfices qu'on peut
il nous semble quand même moins
intéressant alors des enjeux
géopolitiques qui implique des
investissements importants aussi bien au
niveau humain et matériel compte tenu
des risques et des conditions difficiles
dans cette région polaire regarder ce
nouvel extrait
sur la plateforme il y a deux équipes de
secours qui peuvent intervenir si des
accidents surviennent ces personnes ont
reçu une formation spéciale
[Musique]
et
la première équipe de secours composée
de sept personnes est prête pour sa
mission est donc 8 à 10 minutes pour se
préparer
chaque employé à une carte individuelle
portant prénom et nom de famille il faut
l'insérer de manière à ce que le côté
rouge soient orientés vers l'extérieur
cela signifie que cette personne est en
sécurité si quelqu'un n'a pas eu le
temps de le faire
il faut aller la chercher dans la zone
v8 dans la salle des machines du
maintien de la pression
deux détecteurs de fumée déclenché on y
va assumer mois une carte n'est pas en
place les secouristes doivent retrouver
la personne qui ne s'est pas présenté au
point de rassemblement il ya une chance
de la sauver
[Musique]
après oui
sergei prend le avec les demain
vas-y avance c'était un exercice de tel
entraînement on obligatoirement lieu une
fois par semaine les scénarios des
situations d'urgence sont écrits à
l'avancé pour l'année à venir
c'est la victime et sur le brancard
enfin d' alerte
voilà pour ce nouvel extrait darko l'or
noir de la banquise un exercice de
secours à vital on l'a vu c'est vrai que
les trois terres de gisements sont
offshore comme vous le disiez au début
de cette émission c'est donc une
exploitation à haut risque qui n'est pas
accessible à tous les pays les
conditions sont extrêmes tout à fait les
conditions sont extrêmes pour les
conditions de l'off shore sont en
elles-mêmes déjà très difficile que cet
or soit en mer du nord où que ce soit
dans le golfe de mexique
mais lorsque on veut exploiter en zone
arctique
on se retrouve avec des conditions des
contraintes à la fois métérologiques des
contraintes climatiques qui sont qui
sont extrêmement importantes et qui
rendent l'exploitation ou plus difficile
et nécessite aussi beaucoup plus de
précaution une exploitation à haut
risque
ça signifie aussi une exploitation
coûteuse qui nécessitent des
investissements énormes en la matière
justement la russie et leader en matière
de coûts de production d'abord il faut
rappeler que l'exploitation du pétrole
en articles mais aussi du gaz date
d'environ 50 ans les premières
exploitations en zones arctiques ont eu
lieu en alaska c'était le gisement de
prudhoe bay en matière de coûts
les le coup de l'off shore va il est
difficile d'avoir des informations
précises sur les coûts d'exploitation
des différents gisements
il ya des estimations qui ont été faits
montrant que le coût d'investissement
pour des gisements en zone arctique que
ce soit en onshore offshore sont environ
deux fois plus élevé que par exemple les
gisements équivalent au texas
alors justement cette question est-ce
que c'est rentable
au final vu le prix bas du baril
actuellement esque importer du pétrole
par exemple du moyen orient ce n'est pas
ça coûte peut-être moins cher ça coûte
pas moins cher dans la mesure où le
pétrole est achetée au prix du marché
que ce pétrole viennent du moyen-orient
que ce pétrole viennent de russie des
états unis ou de mer du nord
par contre la rentabilité des
investissements est différente et ça
dépend des coûts d'exploitation aussi
bien les coûts d'investissement que les
coûts d'exploitation et donc il est
clair que au moyen-orient le coût
d'exploitation est de l'ordre de 5
dollars par baril et c'est vraiment
absolument impossible d'être compétitifs
par rapport à ces couples les coûts en
d'exploitation en russie défendent
dépendent aussi de la parité entre le
rouble et le dollar et donc ceci à
l'évolution de la pari de la parité a
permis de pétrole russe de rester
compétitif olivier appert on va marquer
une courte pause et poursuivre dans un
instant se débrider donc consacré donc à
ce reportage
arco l'or noir de la banquise à
retrouver sur arte france on se retrouve
tout de suite
on poursuit notre débrief du dock
consacré à ce documentaire arrco l'or
noir de la banquise et nous sommes avec
olivier appert l'ancien pdg d'edf
énergies nouvelles il préside
aujourd'hui le conseil français de
l'énergie
olivier appert c'est vrai que cette
région elle abrite aussi 21 mille
espèces animales végétales les enjeux
environnementaux sont colossaux on va en
parler mais d'abord on va regarder ce
nouvel extrait il s'agit d'une opération
délicate par ce trio le pétrole arctique
est pompée à partir de prirazlomnaïa il
est essentiel est d'assurer l'étanchéité
de la soupape avant le début du
chargement
c'est dangereux la tension est maximale
aux étapes d' approche les fixations du
tuyau et d'amarrage et surtout à celle
du chargement
car le navire est très proche de la
plateforme à 80 mètres environ
le navire mesure en 257 m on peut dire
que la plateforme est à portée de main
[Musique]
sur la plateforme evgeny morozov un
marin de l'île artificielle est
personnellement responsable de
l'amarrage et du chargement du pétrolier
ce point central ici contrôleur central
vannes en position on commence la
vérification de la ligne verte je vous
demande la permission
cette autorisation pour commencer la
vérification de la ligne verte reçu la
ligne verte est un ensemble de
conditions obligatoires
il en a trente au total si au moins l'un
de ces critères n'est pas respectée les
vannes se ferment le déchargement
s'arrête et cela se produit en l'espace
de six secondes
une opération délicate avec le transfert
du pétrole de la plateforme russe vers
un navire olivia peur depuis 1951
l'article s'est réchauffée deux fois
plus vite que le reste de la planète
avec la fonte des glaces et
l'exploitation massive à des ressources
naturelles est ce que la biodiversité de
la banquise est en danger la banquise
est extrêmement fragile et notamment
proportion très importante de krill dans
les eaux arctiques jouent un rôle
fondamental pour l' équilibre global en
fait des milieux marins
il est clair que le réchauffement de la
banquise créer des problèmes
les problèmes se trouvent à la fois en
offshore
mais le réchauffement de la banquise
facilite en fait les exploitations au
sort par contre les problèmes se
trouvent en onshore
avec le réchauffement du permafrost elle
qui peut rendre de plus en plus
difficile la circulation sur la toundra
il ya beaucoup de rng dont greenpeace 1
qui mène une guerre pourra protéger cet
espace en menant des actions en justice
mais aussi des campagnes internationales
en mer qui vise les compagnies diverses
américaines canadiennes et norvégiennes
et russe elles dénoncent un désastre
écologique et contrairement aux
industriels ne considère pas finalement
cette fonte des glaces comme une aubaine
c'est clair que les milieux
cologix ont quand même très inquiet sur
des évolutions qui pourraient altérer un
milieu qui je le rappelle est un milieu
très fragile je voudrais juste rappeler
la catastrophe de l'exxon valdez qui a
eu lieu en 1989 ou un pétrolier
américain s'est échoué en transportant
du pétrole qui venait de l'alaska
on a estimé que de l'ordre de 20 à 40
mille tonnes de pétrole ont été déversés
sur 7000 kilomètres carrés qui ont
pollué 800 800 kilomètres de côtes et on
a estimé que ça va tuer de l'ordre de
300 milles oiseaux donc tous ces
chiffres sont là pour nous rappeler que
le milieu de l'article est un milieu
quand même extrêmement fragile
on en parlait tout à l'heure il existe
un conseil de l'arctique un forum
intergouvernemental qui inclut également
les peuples autochtones aussi un ace que
ces actions ont un réel impact on
promouvoir le développement durable et
la protection de la diversité de cette
biodiversité de cette région je pense
qu'un des problèmes pour le conseil de
l'arctique c'est que il n'a pas de
pouvoirs législatifs et donc il peut
émettre des recommandations
mais en fait il ne peut pas décider
c'est pas comme c'est comme les
instances onusiennes qui ont le pouvoir
en fait de d'imposer des réglementations
spécifiques
est ce que les intérêts signalement
économique prime pour ces pays sera les
intérêts écologiques les intérêts
économiques
effectivement sont importants mais dans
chacun des pays
je pense par exemple à la norvège je
pense au danemark que je pense au canada
donc pour l'ensemble de ces pays la
pression interne des milieux écologistes
et des ong est aussi extrêmement
importante
que chaque pays est amené à trouver
défendre le bon équilibre entre
bénéfices économiques et contraintes
environnementales contraintes
environnementales qui sont poussés au
niveau national par les ong nationales
et à votre avis est-ce que ce conseil de
l'arctique l'a réellement une influence
écoutez je l'espère on va regarder un
dernier extrait à darko l'or noir de la
banquise olivia père nous évaluons
différents paramètres que les ingénieurs
prennent en compte pour donner leurs
recommandations concernant le traitement
du pétrole
la moindre erreur de chiffres pour un
mètre cubes de pétrole chargé peut
entraîner de graves pertes
on va maintenant mesurer la densité du
pétrole à l'aide d'un sim est
automatique
[Musique]
qui est à biot munir 14 ses volumes de
pétrole qui sont déchargées qui sont
finalement calculé à partir de sa
densité
il ya une corrélation directe entre la
quantité livrée et le coût de la
cargaison est ce le pétrole et de haute
qualité
ces caractéristiques répondent aux
normes internationales le pétrole
extrait prirazlomnaïa et d'un nouveau
type à faible teneur en paraffine
indispensable pour la production de
toutes sortes d'huiles son point de
congélation et de mois 48 degrés ce type
de pétrole a été mis sur le marché en
2014 sous le nom darko où petro
l'arctique la banquise qui est un
endroit riche en hydrocarbures et en
pétrole mais aussi riche par la qualité
de ses ressources naturelles on vient de
le voir dans cet extrait quelle est la
particularité de l'arrco le pétrole
article le pétrole article n'a pas de
particuliers de particularités
spécifiques
en fait toute façon la qualité du
pétrole varient d'agissements un autre
et on est amené pour aussi à faire des
mélanges entre des pétroles de diverses
sources de façon à pouvoir obtenir les
bonnes qualités mais il n'y a pas de
pétrole
qu'ils soient de bonne qualité ou de
mauvaise qualité
il y a des pétroles qui sont des
qualités de pétrole qui sont différentes
d'agissements un autre alors du pétrole
mais aussi du gaz pour la russie
finalement l'enjeu c'est l'indépendance
énergétique à vous avez raison de
souligner l'importance du gaz en fait le
gaz 60 de l'ordre de 75% des ressources
d'hydrocarbures estimées sont sous forme
de gaz et la russie dispose à elle seule
l'essentiel en fait des ressources
gazières
donc ce sont des ressources qui sont
tout à fait considérable avec aussi des
potentiels de nouvelles découvertes qui
sont tout à fait significatives
l'enjeu pour un pays qui peuvent être
des ressources et bien entendu de les
exploiter de façon à améliorer améliorer
son sa richesse il ya beaucoup de
projets gaziers colossaux mené par la
russie a le projet yamal en sibérie est
un projet en cours d'implémentation
c'est l'arc
article 2 ce sont des projets colossaux
s'agissant de yamal précisément le bilan
des activités total est associé à ce
projet le groupe total français total
est effectivement associé à ce projet
avec novatek yamal lng est en fait en
quelque sorte indemne charger sur le
marché gazier dans la mesure où c'est la
première fois que du gaz a été exploité
et transformé en gaz naturel liquéfié et
commercialisé partout dans le monde et
ça a été un succès dans la mesure où le
projet qui est un projet titanesque dans
des zones
quand même extrêmement difficile le
projet a été mené dans les délais et
dans le budget et le succès le premier
succès de yamal lng conduit
effectivement envisager une poursuite
avec arctic lng dont vous parlez et
total qui souhaite aussi être associé à
au projet article 2 en tout cas c'est
une volonté d' emmanuel macron il l'a
fait savoir
total est sur les rangs où est-ce qu'on
en est à ce niveau posez la question à
total je ne peux pas répondre à la place
de total
toujours est il que le succès de lille
yamal lng positionne quand même total
très bien dans ce projet et le succès
aussi de yamal lng fait peut faire
espérer quand même un succès identique
pour
pour article 2 il faut noter que au
niveau mondial toutes les estimations
qui sont faites prévoit une augmentation
significative de la consommation de gaz
et en particulier de la consommation de
gnl avec des perspectives de tensions
sur le marché du gnl par insuffisance
d'offres d'ici 2030
l'enjeu pour la france aussi fait
l'indépendance énergétique aussi le gnl
le gnl qui sera produit ira pas
forcément en france il peut venir en
france mais vraisemblablement il ira
plutôt vers l'asie en particulier vers
la chine compte tenu de l'ouverture des
nouvelles routes maritimes aude or dans
le contexte de réchauffement climatique
mais de façon significative
une des premières cargaisons de yamal
lng est arrivé au terminal méthanier de
dunkerque
les fresh l'exploitation du gaz
conventionnel et peut permettre de
concurrencer justement le les états unis
qui misent sur le gaz de schiste
effectivement le les états unis ont
développé depuis une quinzaine d'années
des ressources nouvelles d'hydrocarbures
non conventionnels ce qu'on appelle le
pétrole et le gaz de schiste les
etats-unis ont développé des capacités
d'exportation en particulier de gnl il
est exclu d'exporter vers la chine vers
l'europe par gazoduc
et dans ces conditions le gnl américain
de gaz de schiste concurrence les
approvisionnements traditionnelle à la
fois de gaz russe par gazoduc
mais aussi du gnl du moyen-orient ou
maintenant du gnl russe l'article c'est
vrai riche en ressources naturelles on a
cité le gaz le pétrole il ya aussi
d'autres minerais l'faire l'un et lors
important pour la conception de
smartphones et d'ordinateurs
l'avenir de l'exploitation de ses
ressources naturelles
en arctique je crois que ses ressources
naturelles
on en aura besoin donc il est nécessaire
de les exploiter
par contre le compte tenu de la
fragilité de la zone arctique dont on a
parlé
il est absolument indispensable de
prendre des précautions tout à fait
particulière de façon à ne pas avoir un
accident comme l'accident de l'exxon
valdez ou d'autres accidents du même
genre pour inciter que cet accident là
il ya une a eu d'autres à la marée noire
de 2010 dans le golfe du mexique ou
encore lorsque shell a perdu une
plateforme en alaska merci beaucoup
olivier appert pour cet éclairage qui
nous invite à voir et à revoir
ce documentaire arrco l'or noir de la
banquise à retrouver en intégralité sur
rtl france
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt
[Musique]